I've seen things that I'd never seen
before you know the proudest moment of
my life has been taken away because of
that
the people that know me would say I'm a
nice guy born to pitch I had to be a
different person if I wanted to succeed
the top level players that I played with
Lampard John Surrey Steven Gerrard I
think look like they don't enjoy it
constantly battling for the next thing
were they intense so intense yeah and
you know a big reason why I'm the person
I am I pay for England and era where it
felt like there was a huge pressure you
know we had an opportunity to win World
Cups and because we didn't it was heaped
on players I've got my mum my dad and
friends in the crowd and then you come
on and get both at five seventy thousand
it's hard to come back from that my mom
was crying my dad had to have a fight I
was thinking about giving up football I
think I wasn't seen as what an England
Striker should look like I was so scared
I was just wanted to hide away in that
phase you were turning to drink more
than you should have been well I alluded
to at that time you're not seen as
people it's like you're well paid so you
have to endure this abuse you know you
put yourself in a position to be shot at
but like what I've seen with certainly
Harry MaGuire the criticism goes beyond
criticism it's gone too far
so proud to represent my country but
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
Pizza
where do I need to start in your story
to really understand
you what's the most pertinent relevant
things that someone listening to this
needs to know about you to understand
you
um
well right at the start I suppose I
think it's everything comes from
um your childhood right
um
I am who I am and shaped by by my
parents and my friends uh and I suppose
people see me now obviously like I had a
determination to be a footballer a huge
determination to be a footballer
and then people see me now
um as a footballer who has a laugh I
suppose and that is my Persona um and
but that stems from from my childhood
really and being a little bit different
looking a little bit different and
having a maybe a defense mechanism
um and that humor or probably that you
see which is me now
um yeah it was a little bit of a defense
mechanism when someone came at me I'd
always be funnier than they would be and
then that stops
whoever saying it in their tracks you
know and then that being so tall at such
a young age was was difficult at times
but
that kind of defense mechanism was
I laugh at myself before you can laugh
at me and that stood me a good stead and
and even now that's you know that's the
way I get through things when was that
when was the first time that you that
you realized that you were
different because like I remember coming
to the UK from Botswana in Africa and I
was the only black kid in Norway school
and there was like there's some day I
think I remember specifically a comment
that a kid made to win the playground
which really put into like perspective
that I was actually different to them it
was something about my hair
um I had like a little little like kind
of Jackson 5 afro going on that I'd
combed out and from that day onwards
there was I kind of noticed that I was
different can you recall a time where
you've you realize that you being taller
Was Made You Different yeah well I think
it's only it's only people with with
experience like older people that that
notice anything like that isn't it
really I think like as kids we just grow
up everyone's the same aren't they and
then
um it's older kids so like when I was
you know I was always the tallest in my
class but my mum and dad may have never
made a big deal of it up to me
um I was always taller than everyone
else and then when we started to play
football and then when I started to be
good at football you would hear things
on the sideliner yeah but he's a couple
of years older or yeah he's good but
he's he's too old and um because you're
only judged by your height at that at
that age so I would hear things from the
parents and then um you know I'd hear
like little remarks like people laughing
little Japes and jiving and
um yeah because like people saying or
you're skinny or your lanky is is seen
as um it's sort of like you're allowed
to say it in some ways do you know what
I mean like
it's just it's a describing word but
like that's how it was for me
um but I love it it feels to me like
it's part of me it's me now I've always
been taller than everyone else it wasn't
as if I just shot up
um and was different I was just always
ahead above everyone else and that is a
part of me now which I love Richard I
was Richard Osmond who came on the
podcast
um was the first person who kind of
stunned me into silence because I have
to be completely honest I didn't realize
that
heightism
abusing people for being tall
was such a sort of consequential
um
thing for those people I was one of the
people who who didn't didn't realize
that someone who's lived their height
being very very tall will be told about
it everywhere they go every second and
how that can impact someone and how they
feel it honestly I remember doing that
podcast I remember sitting here [ __ ]
oh of course of course it'd be like
anything else with me if I had the third
arm and everyone said everywhere I go it
would make me subconscious about it
exactly right yeah
um and you know it's because there's
bigger problems everywhere you know
there's bigger problems but my prob my
problem or you know it was I think it
was different was my height you know
like I I recently you know added did a
joke of like all the questions that I
was permanently asked I had a a series
of cards in my inside pocket to answer
every single question that everyone the
people I knew were going to ask me so it
was uh what's the weather like up there
um do you play basketball uh how tall of
you
um do you sleep in a grow bag is the
weather different up there right five
questions but I had all the answers in
my inside pocket so before they even
open their mouth I could give them a
card
um and it was just something funny you
know that that changed the subject but
it's amazing how many times I think it's
less so now because people know who I am
and know what I'm about but before
um people I became well known
um those questions were just constant
what impact is that we joke about it as
you know now but what impact does that
have on a young man well it on an
impressionable young teenager it had a
it had a big impact
um me now you know it's water for ducks
back you know it doesn't it doesn't
matter to me
um but yeah as a young lad it was it was
a little bit different I remember my dad
getting you know really angry about it
um
because as a teenager you're going
through things that are a little bit
um you know you're always you're not
comfortable within your own skin are you
as a young as a young lad
um so I was the same as everyone else
but I found it difficult at times really
difficult and especially football
Terraces like as I got older and I was
playing professionally
um and then I started playing in the
first team
and all of a sudden it was like you know
dealing with there's one thing dealing
with the odd person in the in the street
saying oh aren't you talking and another
thing dealing with 30
000 people screaming like
of Senate is that you you know taking
the piss out of the way you look
laughing at you
that that was difficult
when you say difficult what do you mean
um in a practical because I read it like
14 and 15 years old you're crying
yourself to sleep sometimes because of
this and having conversations with your
dad about it yeah yeah I think there was
times where I thought to myself is it is
it worth it is it worth going through
this
um why am I putting myself through this
it's all I've ever loved it's all I've
ever wanted to do
but if people are going to laugh at me
and take the piss out of me
um what is the point you know
um do I want it that much I was lucky I
had a good support network around me you
know I had good people around me my dad
was was great with me he'd always and he
was harsh with me at times as well but
he was also really really good and at
pulling me back up and sort of giving
myself more confidence and
um listen I don't look like your average
footballer and I've known that since I
was 10 11 years old you know when I
watched football on the TV I don't see
anyone that represented me
um really like the odd like tour Andre
Flo was was potentially one had good
technique
um there was a couple of players that
but but not many so I thought to myself
maybe I'm just not I'm not right maybe I
don't look right I don't I shouldn't be
a player you know I had all these things
going on in your mind but
ultimately if you know I had the
determination and I had the ability to
and I suppose the thick skin which you
have to have to to go past it
you said that there was thoughts in your
head of maybe I should maybe I should
quit maybe I should go do something else
was were those like real considerations
you had
at some point oh without doubt they were
that was um I I'm just I just think to
myself is it worth it like why I always
remember the game it was West Brom away
and I came on and uh
I missed the chance and nobody knew who
I was I was just a kid you know I was
probably the same height as I am now and
probably about
I was probably about nine Stone nine and
a half Stone I was you know much
skinnier than I am now believe it or not
and I'm trying to be a premier league
player you know it's just
people just thought it was absolutely
ridiculous and at times I thought it
myself I thought well I know I've got
ability but I'm looking at these big
strong you know developed men like I
can't compete with this
um I always remember coming on people
actually laughing at me and then
um there was another game away at
Gillingham where I just got absolutely
abused to the point where you know
people were shouting freak and does the
circus know you're here like this these
were these are the things that what
people were saying and uh my dad was in
the crowd I always remember it I was
walking
I was walking uh out
uh at half time of the game and my dad
was rolling down the aisle in in the
Gillingham and having a fight with
someone I thought oh my God this is not
this is my first season in professional
football I think my dad's having a fight
I'm getting absolutely abused my mom's
crying
you know what am I doing why why am I
putting myself through this of course I
love football and that's you know what I
want to be but is it worth all this
how do you feel about those people that
are shouting like freak at you when you
come on the pitch and upset in your
family like how do you like think about
them and that kind of culture now like
you know what like it'd be easy for me
to say here sit here and go uh oh you
know the brain dead this that but
growing up in a football culture it was
like I've been there myself on a
football tourist where you you know and
you hear things my dad used to cover my
ears and stuff
um let's go to Chelsea as a kid and
um I don't know it's it's like it's like
almost normal and I know it's wrong and
obviously there's a line you know I mean
obviously we've seen it recently you
know with racism and you know there's
certain things that go well over the
line but you know being tall wasn't
considered you know over the line so it
was something that I just I just decided
was that was the way football is you
know can we change that can I change
that I don't think so so I just got on
with it um and how do I think about them
now I think yeah it was Reckless I think
I think I've sat down on a drillingham
fan that was abusing me that day and I
said shoot you know what you really like
my mom was crying my dad had to have a
fight I was thinking about giving up
football I think you'd I think he'd say
oh God I'm sorry I think he would but
I don't think in that moment
he saw us as as people it's like you're
a footballer on the pitch and
you're not seen as it's like
such tribalism
that you're just gonna
enjoy you have to endure it for you know
you're well paid so you have to endure
this kind of level of abuse
um and I think things are changing you
know I'd like to think they are we're
trying to help that but and certainly in
those days it was a case of
get on with it did that put a chip on
your shoulder you know when you hear
those things and you're running onto the
pitch and you hear people abusing you or
whatever else or you're aware of that
that narrative in your head when you
come on do you think to yourself I'm
gonna [ __ ] show these people
I'm gonna does it give you did it give
you doubt or did it give you an extra
bit of confidence it's a little bit of
both I think like when I was like I I
didn't know whether I was going to play
for England or I was going to be a
non-league player and either of them
would have been fine like I wasn't on
the map to go and play for England you
know I wasn't Steven Gerald I wasn't
Michael Owen I wasn't Wayne Rooney you
know I had a different path I wasn't
ready for the Premier League till I was
22 23 probably you know so I didn't know
where my career was going to go so yeah
there were times where I doubted myself
but then I think you know I think I
scored my first goal
and uh and things just changed and I
just it was well it was the most
important moment of my life and it was
against Gillingham again believe it or
not funny how it comes around but I yeah
chest the ball down and I've only
disappointed I was at QPR and I knew
then that I'd have a career in football
like
I didn't know I'd play for Liverpool I
didn't know I'd play for England but I I
didn't know what I want to achieve but I
knew then I'd have a career in football
and that was where my confidence grew
and and then I thought no no I can do
this your dad
had he was um
quite tough at times
from what I read yeah yeah like really
tough yeah
um what does that mean well
yeah I mean I think at times he probably
went a little bit too too far but like I
wouldn't I wouldn't be sat here having
played for England or I've been playing
achieving the things that I've done
achieving my dreams
without him
being hard on me like I wouldn't would I
go maybe to the lengths at times that he
he did maybe not but what lengths uh
well we um just certain things like I
think the heart the harshest one was
when he um it obviously left me at uh
I was at the ball court in um at
Tottenham and um
I jumped out of a tackle and his thing
was look I came from a nice background
and a lot of kids were playing football
to survive you know so I had to toughen
up and that's the truth like
was I going to go into a tackle like my
life depended on it like the kids from
from the estate around Edmonton or east
London and
probably not at that time so you know
when I got up to
um
after the
after training you're like my dad he'd
gone
yeah yeah so he left me and uh I had to
get home I'm bearing in mind I grew up
in in healing uh getting home from
wildlame with an overground
Seven Sisters talked to the circus
Oxford Circus twirling Broadway and then
walk home from there
um oh it's probably about I was probably
13 or 14.
but I hadn't been on a tube before
I had but not on my own so
it's a tough lesson did he tell you he
was going no I went up there and he was
gone and did you not think I'll give him
a call tomorrow well I didn't have a
mobile yeah yeah yeah it was different
and when did you find out it was because
if you weren't tackling people well I
thought I thought it might be
wasn't no I didn't tackle I think I
remember jumping out of one particular
tackle uh for my dad's gonna kill me for
that uh
do you know what though I never jumped
out of a tackle again and you know
like I say is a harsh lesson
but I'm not gonna I'm gonna sit here and
say
it wasn't the right lesson I think it
might have been a tad harsh
would I do would I do that to my son I'm
not sure
I don't probably not but
I think potentially I'm too I'm too easy
on my kids a bit
um
it's it's a tough lesson to learn but I
think if you want to be a top Elite
footballer
you need to want it as much as the next
person and I did want it but
I I hadn't had to fight as much as these
kids you know and um and don't get me
wrong these kids these kids are they're
my friends now you know like I have some
good some good lads that
came from tough upbringings that went on
to be really good players
um you know ledley King I remember like
ledley King Stephen Mills James Carter
these boys that I met in the bull Court
you know Nikki hunt they were
the tough Lads you know from you know Bo
in in East London you know an estate
where like Ashley Cole grew up Lily King
grew up and and I ended up playing in
the ball court
um where they grew up you know and
that's a different kind of environment
to where I was playing you know but
I think when you can hold your own in
there and you know you can go you can
rough it up you can fly into tackles
I basically changed my whole
personality
well I played football you know like I
can sit here now and I'd like to say
that I'm gonna I'd like to think that
I'm a nice guy I think people that know
me would say I'm a nice guy but on the
pitch I had to be a different person if
I wanted to succeed and then that was
just one lesson when you got home from
that little football game where you
didn't put the tackle or jumped out of
the tackle did your dad have a
conversation with you about it about why
he left yeah so he told you why at the
end he said yeah listen there's a few
things that like sugar remain privacy
remember that but
um
let's just say I was I was told you know
uncertain times to not jump out of a
tackle again okay okay good and your mum
what was your her broader influence on
you yeah mum
um
she is very much like me uh
yeah I think most of my my traits
probably come come from my mum
um
you know obviously the love of football
came from my dad and stuff and you know
he was very good with me but my mum was
uh
was was very good with me and um you
know she was I thank her every day about
you know she's taking me to
to matches I remember seeing her just
you know she was the only mum on the
side with the barley when it was lashing
down and
um she was incredible taking me to
places she was like my shoulder to cry
on she was the person that I would
provide in
um
they're both both very very good and you
know a big reason why I'm the person I
am
those players from the estate that you
you played amongst one of the things I
read about
um
in your book was how
you could see how attitude played such
an important role in who would make it
because getting from like the estate to
you know
sort of Semi-Pro level and then getting
to the Premier League is a long [ __ ]
journey and there's only a few seats at
that top table so when you think about
like why including yourself why in terms
of mindset and attitude some of of your
colleagues and some of your peers made
it and didn't make it what's your answer
to that yeah it's funny like everyone
every footballer that's played for
England or played I've played with in
the Premier League
um they've all got a story all of them
I've got every single one will tell you
a story about the player that was better
than them
that no one knows
um there's so many of them out there and
it's sad
um but for whatever reason injury you
know there's lots of uh temptation as a
young footballer especially when you're
that good
um you know if you're earning money you
don't know how to handle that money
friends and parties you know
distractions of of all different kinds
um you know actually will you know the
determination dedication there's so many
factors alongside ability
um luck there's there's so many factors
um but I sometimes think we don't
you know a lot of the time we look at
the negative side of football
um but I think sometimes when you see
the kids that have come from absolutely
I'm talking absolutely nothing some of
these kids uh who are now playing for
England or you know and they make
mistakes they make mistakes in the
public eye they make mistakes high
profile mistakes and everyone goes ass
footballers you know that's what
that you know that's what they're like
if you'd have seen what they've come
from
to playing in a Champions League final
like I think that's a success story you
know I think sometimes we should
celebrate that fact not not Kinder for
making those mistakes that they've made
um and yeah of course it depends what
kind of if it's you know too too big a
mistake obviously you can't condone some
things but some of these players who
have come basically with no mum and dad
you know someone's picked them up with
one particular player you know not had
any boots I've been thrown on a football
pitch and has ended up playing in a
Champions League final but yeah he's
made of mistakes along the way but I
think sometimes we should we should
consider that a success
yeah we don't really have a lot of
empathy do we when it comes down because
it's because it's because it's a highly
profession
um you know and sometimes
um you know there's a stigma on uh you
know why are these why are these players
getting paid so well
um and I get I get that you know there's
uh there's a lot of money in football
and um you know it's just could it be
spent Elsewhere on people in the NHS or
you know people uh who've you are doing
pretty much more harder jobs than a
footballer but um it is what it is you
can't change it but I do think
um
yeah there is there is that stigma
Associated to footballers I sat with Tim
Grover who was the guy that trained
Michael Jordan and Kobe and he also
trained some Premier League football
players now gives them like coaching
advice and one of the things he told me
was how he's seen the pressure of being
a high-level Premier League football
player completely destroys some players
and it's something that was the first
time I'd kind of heard that because as a
fan as I've always been you know all you
know we're all tweet and we're all
having our say all commenting we're all
at the game shouting in our little mob
mentality whatever but then we don't
really think that the all of that
pressure especially on like as you say a
kid that's come from the estate who's 18
and isn't like doesn't have the tools to
deal with that pressure how they can be
going home out can severely impact their
performance and how it can kind of like
just
cause them to collapse a little bit
um I got to be honest I've seen a
similar thing in my view with like the
the mob
attacking like someone like Harry
MaGuire rashford had it a lot last year
as well but
um what's your take on all of that and
have you seen that yourself in the
dressing room yeah no I've seen it and I
played I've played in um
I'll play for England in Era where
um it was it felt like there was a huge
pressure there was it was the golden
generation you know the players were the
best we've ever had since 66.
um you know we had an opportunity to win
World Cups and you know because we
didn't it was you know it felt like it
was heaped on certain players
um and that kind of pressure but when
you're talking about rashford and and
Maguire like I think we were all
entitled to criticize players like we
put ourselves in that in that position
but like what I've seen with
certainly Harry MaGuire I feel like it
goes it's gone really too far I think
you know it's
it's harsh it's you know I'm just
thinking of his family you know because
I've been in that position I've been
booed for England I've I've remember
playing Old Trafford in the game
and coming on and it's the proudest
moment you'll ever have in your life
and your home fans are burning you know
I've been in that situation and it feels
like Harry MaGuire is going through you
know what seems to be a prolonged period
of this and yeah regardless of form I
think some of you know the Social Media
stuff I see you know ridiculing
um
I think he's having a difficult time to
as a player
but I think some of the criticism goes
beyond criticism it becomes
um too harsh in my opinion
having been in a situation where you've
been booed by the fans of the club
you're playing for
what does that do to you what did it do
to you when you came up was it for
England yeah well that's devastating
yeah I'm um I'm playing for England
listen you know there might be an
element of the fact I was my Liverpool
player I'm an Old Trafford
um you know obviously a lot many live
fans
um
but
it was during the course of when I I
wasn't score of Liverpool and I was
having a real tough time anyway I had 18
games where I didn't score for Liverpool
and um the fact that
it goes back to I I felt like within the
land to be superhuman it goes back to
the thing where because I look different
a bit I I wasn't seen as what an England
Striker should look like
um and I think that was genuinely a
thing
but um I I then you know I'm so proud to
represent my country but I've got my
sister my mum and my dad
uh all friends in the crowd
and everyone's excited you know they're
all talking to me before the game about
you know makeup potentially coming on
and making an appearance getting the cap
and then you come on and get booed by
seventy thousand of your own fans yeah
so so what I'm saying is um don't ever
feel sorry for footballers don't but you
know don't don't have to we we expect
that but
my family like my mom was in bits
um you know the proudest moment of my
life has sort of been taken away a bit
because of that
um
but you know we put ourselves in in the
position there's no I'm not gonna I'm
gonna sit here and and cry about it just
it's just disappointing for my family
more than anything
what happens when the whistle blows the
game ends on days like that you're going
back and see your family is there a bit
of an awkwardness to it a bit of
embarrassment you know because uh you
want to be the one who comes down with a
with a champagne in your hand you know
and everyone claps you in and your
family gives you a big hug you know and
most of the lads did that you know
they've got a shirt they've got a cap
like I'm I'll come down to the Players
Lounge after and I'm a bit sheepish all
right
sorry about that Mom you know it's like
you're apologizing for doing the thing
that you've worked so hard to do your
whole life
um so that is that's difficult
dealing with the
the family side of it because I I know
what I've done I've put myself in a
position to be shot at I'm sure you feel
the same you know doing this podcast
whatever you do that's you know you put
yourself in a position to be shot at but
your mum hasn't you know she doesn't she
doesn't need to hear that and it kills
it killed her but it's funny isn't it
when you're when you put yourself in a
position to be shower I really like that
phrase
um and then you know you get shot at
your family try and stand in the way of
the bullets to some degree yeah and it's
like no no please don't send me the
Articles please don't tell me your
thoughts on it and WhatsApp I don't need
to uh like persuade you out of this
situation and like sort of counsel you
on why these people are saying this
about me so how do you deal with that
how do you deal with like
um you know do you just part of the
guard and pretend it's not happening it
depends on the issue but I mean I'll
probably get canceled once once every
quarter for something I've said on this
podcast or whatever
um Dragon Center sometimes because the
way it's edited it can make it seem like
I said something I didn't say or
whatever but
um so my friends know not to send me
articles just assume I've seen it yeah
yeah I don't need my best maker have you
seen that this is that this is something
that happened like early on in my career
and I was like no stop all that like I'm
not I'm not reading new I don't watch
match of the day if I haven't scored
that's the way I deal with it yeah it's
like you know that doesn't exist yeah
yeah and when I do something good I'm
like online
be very selective in what you watch or
listen to but
was there a moment in Ukraine where you
said I'm not going to read the
newspapers anymore I'm not going to
watch the Telly I'm just gonna yeah was
that that Liverpool Facebook yeah that
liberal phase was like radio silent no I
was gone I was relaxed to the thing like
everyone's the problem with now I could
stop
buying a newspaper I can stop watching
telly I can do other things you know I
can do but nobody can live without their
phone now and this is the problem like
for young footballers that are worried
if I do I'd like you've got to worry
about it because no one can put their
phone down from no one can
um Sony football is the same especially
a young player you know you pick up your
phone for it right I've got what's on
the diary I've got a text message then
you did you find yourself on Instagram
on Twitter or on whatever you're on and
you can't get away from it and they and
no matter what the players tell you
whoever they are I don't listen to it
they they do they do you can't get away
from
what what it is now with the phones you
can't everyone's got one and everyone's
looking
um with me to get through that yeah I
didn't I didn't watch I was getting
ridiculed that time where I didn't score
for Liverpool
was
such a hard time like for me I was just
wanted to hide away in in a in a dark
room until I scored basically so I don't
know what I would do if I was hiding
away in a dark room with a mobile phone
right you might as well just not you
might as well go out and face it all
because it's a lot harsher on the on the
phone than it is when you see people in
person if I was in your so you signed
for Liverpool and then you go 18 games
without screwing 18 appearances right
well that's great
um if I was
in your household at that time if I was
behind the scenes in your Camp what
would have I actually what would have
what would I have seen
um
or someone who's depressed I suppose I
mean outwardly outwardly not I've never
been that person to sort of to wallow in
it you know I've always been the sort of
I suppose a bubbly character I always
see the positive in everything
um but that at that time like it felt
like I was getting ridiculed and it was
really tough I had to sort of fight my
way through it but
what was so amazing was the Liverpool
fans stuck with me and uh that's
something that I'll never forget because
I I swear to you any club in the world
um having just won the Champions League
in one of the best finals we've ever
seen in Istanbul in 2005 they signed me
right I turn up and I don't score for 18
games right I don't think there's a club
a top club in the world that tolerates
that as a fan base
um apart from Liverpool fans and they
stopped by me and it was like a Siege
mentality it was like everyone else is
attacking him but he's one of ours and
we're
um with him and it felt like
every time I played it they were
willingly to score and when I eventually
did
um
you can see the the footage of it the
camera's shaking and like the it's like
we've won a European Cup Final like
people wanted to score that much
and I you know I'm thankful to this day
that they they did stick with me and
because I managed to turn it round after
that and
um it was a special moment uh at a
special Club
I was reading them in that phase you
you were turning to drink more than you
should have been a little bit after
games and stuff yeah because my dad you
know to be fair to him would say to me
and I'd be like no I'm not going out
don't even like you're going out like
he'd make me go out after games and I'd
be like I don't want people laughing at
me but he dragged me out we'd have a few
beers like it wasn't as if I was
drinking at home on my own it wasn't
like a dark kind of thing it was he was
making he was dragging me out and he was
making me have a few drinks and then I
realized actually no one because it's
I've built it up it's everyone's
laughing at me it's my it it's my world
that's
you know not actually no one really
cares you know they might have a laugh
at you on a Saturday but they're going
back to their own lives you know I've if
I feel like it's everyone's laughing at
me at all times you know you build these
things up in your head and they're never
as bad as you think they are so his way
of dealing with it you know with me was
to take me out for a beer and yeah I
probably did drink a little bit more
than I should do as a as a premier
league player but I needed to at that
time
and you you bounce between what six
clubs before the age of 25.
yeah six yeah that's a lot of moving
it's a lot of moving around yeah but I I
classed that as um like if I'm if I'm at
Liverpool or you know you're starting
Manchester United or Chelsea you know
Bayern Munich Real Madrid you don't have
to move anywhere if you're playing do
you don't have to the course of my
career was very different to anyone
else's courses of my career and those
moves that I had where QPR was I had a
chance to Showcase my talent you know I
did very well the club went into
Administration I went to Portsmouth and
they bought me for like a record fee I
then
um did really really well in a
championship and got a move to Aston
Villa in a premier league you know I
felt like my dream had arrived
and then it didn't quite work out I
wasn't ready for the Premier League um I
always remember my debut was against
Newcastle and Alan Shearer was up the
other end of the pitch and I was at this
end of the pit obviously the the
opposite Striker and I thought if that's
what I need to be a premier league
player
I'm not one I'm not one because he was
so good and I and I I just thought
I maybe I maybe I'm a championship
player
um so I ended up having to move again uh
to Southampton to get games and then
things took off so like all my moves
were like
for for a reason for the from a club
point of view or for a financial thing
for the club or for me having to go out
and get football or for me to progress
as a player so I would have loved
nothing more than to stay at one club
for my whole life uh but that wasn't
that wasn't my journey you moved from um
Liverpool to Spurs
um how would you sort of summarize your
time at Spurs
um I I absolutely loved it because I
started at Spurs as a youngster and I
played in that book called White heart
Lane and I tried to play in a youth team
and I was in the reserves and me and
ledley King came through together
ledley when you obviously was there and
I went throughout all this whole journey
of Liverpool England QPR Portsmouth
Southampton or Norwich on loan dulwich
Hamlet alone
and I came back to Tottenham and ledley
was in the same place I left him
which was
another first team for Tottenham I'd
come through there in the youth team I
had so many players ahead of me I wasn't
ready so for when I when I come back for
10 million pounds and I I'd already
played in the Champions League final I
played in a World Cup
eyes achieve things
that nobody in that Tottenham sort of
dressing room at the time would would
say I would achieve I wasn't even good
enough for you know to play in their
first team which is correct at the time
so to come back it felt like unfinished
business if you like so
so then when I scored some important
goals for Spurs and we got into the
champions league for the first time and
we had good success
um that felt like it was almost like a
coming home if you like and that ended a
little bit to abruptly for your liking a
bit yeah yeah it did
um
I I liked it at Spurs it was it was
funny because I uh
it was deadline day and um
they Harry redknapp was talking about
bringing Emmanuel alviorian and it's
funny how it works for a footballer but
I I went
to work
call it work for now and I left Abby and
and the kids and I said um
I'll see you I'll see you this afternoon
and then this afternoon never came I
never came home
and I'll just give her a course if we
live in Stoke now
it's the life of a footballer I was
happy he had a two-year contract left at
Tottenham
but I was just you know that bit came in
of 10 million pounds for a 30 year old
and I can understand from a club's
perspective
that they wanted to accept your father
they wanted to bring added by Oren and I
spoke to Harry and he said obviously
yeah we do want to bring out a buyer in
but Daniel Levy wants to accept this bid
um
obviously I wasn't happy about it you
know I was happy where I was I was at a
great club and I wanted to stay but um
certain bits and pieces happened and uh
I said to have where uh we're on the
move
how does Daniel he's a a figure that's
talked about a lot as being quite a
tough tough guy he does does very um
what's the word tough business that's
what I hear a lot
well listen this is you know star River
CEO right yeah if I was around the
football club I'd probably have him in
charge really yeah it is a harsh
businessman right but
is looking after you know a billion
pound asset you know he's
he's not necessarily the owner but he's
running it like it's his own
um and I think
I understand that like the the bid of 10
million came in for me I'm a I'm an
asset to the business and I know I'm a
person but if you look at it purely from
from a business perspective
I'm a depreciating asset at 30 years old
potentially I went on to 38 to be fair
but in his eyes maybe
um Wilson Palacios was was another six
millions ago so 16 million they're
getting four it's good money it's good
business potentially
but you know I'm not I'm not stupid
either so
I had two years left on my deal and you
must have had it been over well if you
think about it he's getting 16 million
right yeah
um it's not yeah it's not like I know
what he's getting you know
I'm entitled to to see some of that if
you want me to leave
I did okay and it worked out for for
both of us
um
but I don't know I don't think there's
many people that come out of a
maybe an incident like that with Daniel
leaving and come out
smiling
um because he is he is Harsh
um but like I say you know I had my
running with him and there were times
where I said no it's okay I'm happy I'll
see you in the morning I'm happy at
Tottenham I was comfortable there
and I just said I'll see you in the
morning and uh you know I suppose you've
got to be prepared to hang out the phone
and say say that
um and then he kept coming back and
telling me that I wouldn't get a squad
number
I wouldn't um I'll be training with the
kids
trying to make my life difficult uh and
I was like no problem what was that
initial conversation he calls you in and
says you're off do they not say I'm
interested in the world of football like
because in the world I'm from in
business
there's a high degree of empathy it's a
very you know conversation there's
performance reviews it's very but we
don't have an impending deadline day
either so I'm just trying to figure out
if it's like a go get your stuff you're
off or if it's uh but I think I think I
think it would be different if you did
have a deadline day you know yeah
so I I think you know that rushes people
obviously but
um yeah definitely your scene like
there's a there's this there's this
whole thing about a player should show
loyalty and but there's also works both
ways you know you know Club clubs at
times uh if you aren't performing or
you're maybe having other issues or
problems off the field uh sometimes that
side of it doesn't get shown as well you
know where the club will quite happily
get rid of you
um so yeah it works it works both ways
um but yeah unfortunately the the
business that they're in is what is fine
and selling players and winning football
matches and ears of Ruthless industry
um but I went into that I've realized
that very quickly to be quite honest
um but I'll I'll enter that with with
open eyes do you do you regret leaving
Liverpool yeah
I'll do a bit I had a I had a great time
at Portsmouth though so and some of
those memories were will stay with me
forever but leaving Liverpool is a
difficult thing to do and um
I was playing for England at the time
and I was loving playing for England I
was playing well and I just thought we
signed philando Torres
alum
on pragmatic I understand my role if you
know what I mean as a player he was
better than me right so what do I do now
uh he's always going to play formed a
great partnership with Stephen Gerrard
um he's on absolute fire I still believe
myself I still believe I can play for
England I'm still a very good player I'm
just not on torres's level so I think
he's not
he just wasn't getting injured the whole
time I was there and then
you know I'd left
and then he he was sold quite quickly to
to Chelsea
and I saw players obviously that were
playing
Andy Carroll yeah I mean you know Andy
Carrollton you know there was Warren in
and Gog players that um I felt that you
know I basically I felt like I should I
could have played
um I haven't said that I'll never looked
back
I've not looked back on any of my people
even say to me now like do you miss
football no I don't miss football that
was a time that I had that was the best
I look back with such fond memories of
it same at Liverpool I don't think ah
should have played there for 10 years
it would have been nice
but it was that I still cherished the
moments that I had with Liverpool and
also the people I've met some great
people at Portsmouth and it's a such a
good club and that was just off the back
of winning the FA Cup and I really
thought we'd get into the to the
Champions League our team was that good
so
it was a it was a it gave me the
opportunity to play and to enjoy my
football and to carry on playing for
England so do I regret it it's the one
thing I look back on and think could I
have stayed and could have I've been a
top top club for longer but I love my
time at Portsmouth as well you mentioned
Gerard there and I've seen you
um talk about Lampard and Beckham and
Gerard and carragher
what was it that made those individuals
great in your view what did you see
I saw something in like in those players
that uh
that was slightly different to me like
I'm not gonna I enjoy it
what I was doing like I looked at the
the top top level players that I played
with and they never looked like they
enjoyed it ever
like yeah Gerard
carragher a class in that John Terry
Lampard like the
it was always the next game you know and
I think that's the top level mentality
you need to have like for me at times
I'd go we'd oh we've won this Landslide
let's enjoy this one a little bit
because we had a massive game on Tuesday
they would already be thinking about
yeah that was good
but it's about the next one it's always
about the next one
and
I admire that in people
um and I I had a I had a Steely
mentality but I also thought
what are we doing it for you know what
yeah of course it's about winning
trophies
but also it's about this moment we've
just won like a huge game like in the
last minute let's celebrate this moment
and deal with tomorrow tomorrow
whereas sometimes the top level players
right here yeah like Steven Gerard prime
example of that
um
just a constant
it looked like there was there was no
enjoyment obviously it was enjoyment at
times but it felt like it was just the
next game was
was more important than enjoying this
one
and yeah of course it was but
I was always a little bit like can I
just enjoy this one a little bit
um
which is you know I think separates the
I'd class myself as an elite Sportsman I
played at the top level but I'm talking
top top
um and that's why they're
who they are were they intense so
intense yeah yeah that's what but I
think that's what separates people isn't
it I think
you know you've got to want to
um sacrifice everything and you know I
did when I was when I was younger and I
did throughout my career but what I'm
saying is that it's that point five
percent that one percent difference of
um
I've just already thinking about the
next game of you know managers Do It um
and as players sometimes
we of course enjoy that win and and
think about the next game when it when
it comes but the top level players that
I've played with like you say Lampard
John Terry
Steven Gerrard
Jamie carrigo I put in that you know the
demo United boys like the consistent
winners are the ones that
I think look like they don't enjoy it
and um because they are constantly
battling for the next
the next thing well we've got I read
that you said um some players couldn't
deal with the intensity of a Steven
gerund and a carragher and that you also
were much more orientated to try and
please them than the manager which I
think was Rafa at the time that's right
you were trying to please more concern
with pleasing carragher and Gerard who
are the you know like Club Captain
Captain whatever of the team than the
manager yeah that's true
I'm trying I'm trying to put myself into
the changing moments and and understand
why that is what were they doing
um
they're local boys right they're they're
Legends at the club
um when I think of Liverpool I think of
Stephen Gerard and and Jamie carragher
um like Rapha Benitez I suppose was a
top manager and he signed me and I you
know I I got only good words to say
about him but
absolute Legends of the club and um
quite ruthless in there and and quite
harsh in their appraisal of some players
uh so I found myself in constantly
seeking their approval and my training
was
you know I always remember the first
training session when Steve wrapped a
ball into my into my feet and I
miscontrolled One
and it's like it's like a one look
would be
you know you don't do that here you're
in Liverpool now it's one one Bad Touch
isn't tolerated here so he said it's
only a look but it was enough to to make
me not do that again you know that that
kind of
standards are different and I think you
get that from from certain players like
like Stephen and Jamie would they go
individuals oh yeah yeah I mean it's
their Club you know and I think some
people didn't understand that
um the level of passion that they had
for
the club uh and like there's players
that on you know everyone's different
like you you'll know only so well like
in a in a place of work if there's no
two character to say you know so you
need to know what what makes people tick
and um
some people couldn't understand the
level of
of passion that they had for the club of
standards that they had they might have
come from a more relaxed Club but
unfortunately if you want to play for
Liverpool you have to have a certain
um way about you in a certain standard
and that you've below that standard then
players like Stephen and Jamie would
show you very quickly in front of
everyone yeah yeah yeah I mean I've seen
I've seen players be signed and be
written off in one training session you
know really 15 million pound players
coming in and like he's [ __ ] really but
I never like
it died I mean that was
you wouldn't get many chances
um
but then I've also seen players be
written off and then come back
um which obviously in their eyes would
would make them a good good fit for for
Liverpool
what do you think of Liverpool right now
uh got the new Nunez guy coming yeah I I
like Nunez I think you know he's a bit
I think it's going to take him time to
settle in I don't think we've seen the
best of him yet but um as a club what
Jurgen klopp's done there you know I
think I look at young kids now who just
expect Liverpool to win champ the
Champions League or win the leagues
um you know I suppose 30 odd years
before it was a long time and Jurgen
klops just changed the DNA back into
you know where they were in the 80s I
mean is that it's that good and yeah
they're struggling a little bit now
um but what he's done for that football
club has has been nothing short of
incredible and you know we had some
great players at my time at the club but
um you know what they've done as a group
has surpassed anything that um you know
that that spell I had Has Done Quick One
some of you may know we've got a brand
new sponsor for this podcast it's
American Express and this partnership
still blows my mind as I'm an avid user
of American Express so with that being
said let me tell you about their new
business Platinum Card benefits firstly
new card members will receive a 200
pound annual Travel credit to be spent
when you spend at American Express
Travel online on flights hotels and car
rentals secondly if you need help with
your expenses then American Express
business cards offer Amex expense which
is simply a brand new and free expenses
Management Service for its business
platinum card holders where you just
need to upload your receipts and
invoices as you go this streamlined
system can be integrated with your
accounting software you will also be
able to Monitor and generate expense
reports straight through Amex expense
platform a total Game Changer and it
saved me so much time and lastly as an
American Express business Platinum Card
member you have access to a wide variety
of American Express offers including
digital subscription to the times the
Sunday Times worth 300 pounds so if
you'd like to find out how you can get
your hands on your new American Express
business card then search American
Express business platinum card to find
out more quick one from our longest
standing sponsor hero I I can't tell you
over the last I'd say over the last
really it's been about two and a half
years it was really um post pandemic how
much my health has become such a huge
priority in my life and I have this
laser laser focused on what I'm putting
into my body it's funny because as you
get older you can start to feel the
things you're putting into your body
more and more and more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so Jurgen Rafa um how many managers
did you work work under your time
um with lows over the uh almost ten God
that's probably more than that probably
more than that for you from working with
more than 10 footballing managers at
varying different levels and also at the
very very top of international and
Premier League football what made a
really good manager
um I I think there's lots of ways to
manage and you know I did my coaching
badges just before I retired and you try
and use a little bit of the good stuff
out of out of everyone but you know
obviously Rapha very tactically
um you know Harry Harry redknapp was a
great people person you know like he
understood people and what they wanted
and uh he made it a nice sort of
environment you know Sven the same was
so relaxed you know in a pressured
environment when you were going into a
World Cup
you just spend out that aura of calmness
around you which you you needed
um so like yeah great managers that I've
had along the way
um but very very different qualities in
in all of them
what about the the opposite what was the
instances where you thought that's not
good management
um
well there were certain things like uh
you know with rafroth there was a
tendency to be too intricate to be too
um methodical to
um precise at times
if you could mix a little bit of raffle
a bit of Harry together off of it you'd
have the perfect manager because
with with Rafa it was like we're playing
Wolves at home and we've got Steven
Gerard Javier Alonso uh Fernando Torres
we've got the best back four in the
league at the moment
um and one of the best goalkeepers just
go out and beat them you know like I
don't think it's that difficult I don't
think you have to play with a couple of
holding Midfield players and you have to
have all you know this what we do if we
don't just go and beat them we're at
anfield
let's go and express ourselves
um and that was my only criticism you
know like that that I could have I think
there was too many times where we
we're thinking about the opposition
instead of saying we're Liverpool let's
go and let's go out and Ambassador them
who was the best manager you played for
um
what is you know there's so many reasons
for for each moment Jerry Francis gave
him my debut Graham Rex was a big
influence on my
on my career
um you know there's good qualities of
Sven I thought Rapha was at times was
incredible when some of the work they
did some of the sessions and someone
that's things tactically were were
really eye-opening
um but Harry redknapp was I I don't
think I'll be sitting here without him
um
just because he understood football he
understood a player
and he understood how to get the best
out of you and I think he got the best
out of me
uh certainly at at Portsmouth you know
at Southampton at Southampton I was
struggling I thought
I've just had a a horrible time at Aston
Villa
this isn't my time in the Premier League
and it's not going well I'm not playing
the manager leaves Harry comes in and he
goes you know this is my last chance
Saloon
and I'm thinking right well maybe I'm
just a championship player Harry comes
in it just changes like that he says you
and Kevin FedEx will be in my front too
uh for the rest of the season you'll
score us enough goals for us to stay up
and uh
just that confidence that belief and
what like
I suppose I uh
I felt my height for you know for the
first time that season and I went out
and scored 16 goals I think after
Christmas I was on absolute fire got in
the England squad and moved to Liverpool
at the end of the year
um so that that little spell of six
months was crucial
um to my development as a as a player as
a person and would I be sitting here
without that you know there's lots of
things you look at
you know would I be would I be here
without that without that and there's
lots of really key important moments and
that was definitely one of them Harry
coming in it's crazy how much is like
someone believing in you at some point
where maybe you don't believe in
yourself can have such a huge impact on
how you're behaving and ultimately what
results you get yeah if you're if you're
getting told that you're you know you're
this and you're that you're no good
you're it's not I don't I don't think
you have to be a real strong character
to to be able to to cope with that
um and when someone comes in and goes
actually no you're you're doing great
stuff you know keep you like yeah it
lifts you it does it makes you feel it
makes you feel better and um you know
that's the way I would manage and that's
the way I think you have to manage these
days I think players are different to to
to how it was when I was coming through
it was very much quite harsh industry
and I think now players are a bit more
you have to be a bit more of an arm
around the shoulder guy
you know
um crack the whip kind of manager when I
sat here with like Patrice and Patrice
Evra Gary Neville Rio Ferdinand they all
say the same thing about Sir Alex the
first comment they'll make when you ask
why he was so good they all say Mana
management and they tell this story of
how he was kind of this bespoke almost
like a unique shape jigsaw piece for
each person so for Nanny
he was one Sir Alex Ferguson and for
like for Gary Neville he was a different
shape because he understood everybody
and understood which plans to press how
hard he could press to get the best out
of them and we tend to think of like
management as
one been one thing like being one uh one
person to everybody but even from what
you've said there and what they've told
me it seems that great management is
being like a bit of a shape-shifter
depending on who you're dealing with I
think that is exactly right I think
you've hit the nail on the head there
and the boys that you know you talk
about there of uh it's spot on because
you can't treat everyone the sort of
saying well you can't even train the
same way if you go in you know you're
telling all the players to go in the gym
and you know do this do a certain weight
or you know be a certain speed you can't
everyone is different everyone's a
different character everyone's a
different mold as a player
um you know certain players you can like
Canton are for instance you talk about
Ceramics Ferguson you know not many
players could could handle cancer Alex
Ferguson got the best out of Canton are
because he treated him different to how
he would treat Gary Neville and it's not
you know it's not rocket science but
it's it's something it's a quality that
not many people have they're not able to
adapt it's like this is my management
style everyone has to fall in line with
it I I don't think
as a manager that is the best way to go
about things it's about adapting to to
people that you might need to speak to
on a regular basis certain people you
might need to tell
you know some home truths certain people
that you might need to
um you know constantly get into the
office or you know let someone else deal
with him potentially you know you might
spot a problem that it might have off
the field that needs addressing you know
there's so many factors to being a
manager
um and I think Alex Ferguson was well
he's proven to be the best at that
reminds me of watching that Netflix
documentary about Michael Jordan and
called The Last Dance brilliant
brilliant [ __ ] night changed my life
now I think I like I've got like a
Michael Jordan thing upstairs oh yeah
yeah I always you know when people ask
me if I was a basketball player I
actually wanted to be there
it was uh not a phenomenal documentary
yeah changed really really changed I'll
be honest and people will be surprised
to hear this I understood that Michael
Jordan made shoes but I didn't really
know who he was before then and when I
watched that it was one of those ones
where you put it on and you watch the
whole thing in one sitting I was it
changed my life you're younger than me I
remember him clear as day they're really
playing with the balls yeah I mean he I
think he's the greatest Sportsman that's
ever been as a controversial statement
you know there's so many Sportsmen out
there but what Michael Jordan did was
was was unbelievable and that like I
loved that kind of mentality going into
that mentality of like winning at all
costs and
um watching that balls thing because he
wasn't just Jordan like that that whole
that whole team was was special that's
what I was gonna say like Dennis Rodman
he was a character aware which sounds to
look much like Cantona in a way where
yeah he would go on Benders for a couple
of days yeah he goes listen that's
Dennis
so honestly no I want everything yeah
exactly but like that's what I'm saying
you're like could you Dennis was a huge
part defensively of that setup with the
balls and uh if you didn't have him if
you didn't I don't know let him I think
this is obviously like you know that
probably too far but let him go to Vegas
for a couple of weeks at least you get
Dennis back for those games at the end
that are important and I think it's
obviously ridiculous for him to do that
but
that was his in his makeup that was in
his DNA and you know is it is it better
for you to let him go to a rival or do
you do you accept that
and when the
win the titles they did
all the great managers like the ones
we've talked about seemed to have
instances where they were okay to make
an exception I guess the risk is what
message does that send to the other
players it's almost a bit of an
unfairness if how Cantona or Dennis
Rodman or whoever can go and do that
yeah you're having me [ __ ] show up
every day and you're pressing me in a
different way that's not fair well yeah
I I totally agree with you
um but I don't know if the boys told
this story last time but
um you know the story of of of Ryan
Giggs um when they turn up for a team
event and he's got no tie on and Eric
Canton walks in with no title pair of
trainers and uh Alex Ferguson's
obviously absolutely you know Kane Ryan
Giggs and told him to go home and get
get a tie on like who do you think you
are Eric walks in sits down doesn't say
a word
really yeah because
is Sarah cancer now you know and I think
Ryan Giggs was just a this is just
capable of of winning a football match
is there a cancer now but where you do
where where this does fall down is when
those players stop performing and I've
seen that I've seen players get treated
differently
and that's fine until
they're not Eric Cantona they're not
Michael Jordan they're not Tiger Woods
they're not constantly winning games for
you because if you set yourself up like
that
you you better perform and a lot quite
often they can because the top players
but you are
you are creating a problem for yourself
I think if you if you don't consistently
deliver but maybe that's the reason they
do consistently deliver because they are
wired up differently to a lot of the
rest of us which kind of makes me think
about Ronaldo
and what happened the other week with
him storming down the tunnel etc etc now
me and my friends in our group chat we
all have kind of different points of
view on it you know people are saying oh
Sir Alex would have let him do that this
whatever whatever for as someone that's
been inside the changing room and
probably seen seen moments where a
certain player was being disruptive
what was your read on that situation and
the impact of it but it's in all honesty
it's nothing new I think it's because
it's Ronaldo it's a huge story but I've
seen it over the course of my career at
players who aren't playing
call it throwing the toys at the prom
um you know being uh disruptive uh
letting their feelings be known that
they're not happy with the situation
um as players it's constantly happening
so you don't worry because it's Ronaldo
it's blown out of proportion I've seen
it many times I've seen it with a
particular player we're playing in a
pre-season match he just walked off the
pitch while we're playing
you know this is absolutely ridiculous
he's literally walked over down to 10
men and no one even noticed he'd gone
for the first couple of minutes and um
just yeah like just just fuming um but
my take on the situation is I I think
it's disrespectful to the players that
are playing still they've just won
um or just they were winning at the time
uh I think
it was something that he probably
regrets
um and I think it's something that the
manager dealt with and I think dealt
with well yeah that's what I was going
to say because I remember you saying
that good managers that you've worked
with could keep the respect and that
being a keyword respect now if he
doesn't deal with that properly
without doubt I mean listen players are
on every little moment like if you don't
know the answer to a particular question
lie and lie well because players will if
they if they sense an element of you've
been unsure about a situation they'll
pounce on it
um you know you're talking about a
manager I'm talking about management
managers you know players if you're if
you're a manager and you don't have
control of the dress room at all times
it's hard to come back from that like
you need to command respect and
um it's a harsh industry like lots of
players with egos uh and trying to
manage players that aren't playing with
those egos is a tough thing to do and
when you've got someone of the stature
of Ronaldo like managing him not playing
in the dressing room is a difficult
thing to do you know put yourself in 10
hard shoes it's a it's a situation where
the club have I think I believe told me
he has to stay because they want to play
him now he's not playing and the
window's shut
how do you deal with that problem it's
it's going to be a huge issue but I felt
we dealt with it well I think the club
potentially didn't do very very well if
he wasn't going to play they should have
they should have sold him
but they're now in that situation where
yeah he's done that he's been fined I
assume and he's been dropped for the
next Squad but it looks like he's
potentially
getting back in
um and that is what is is the best
situation for the club because you don't
want Ronaldo training with the kids away
from the
um away from the first team you want him
in and around it because he'll be an
asset potentially at the end of games or
or to start some games I'm really
compelled by that point you made about
like as a manager if you don't know the
answer to maybe a strategic thing you're
better off just lying than like losing
the control of the room well like say if
you're in your industry right if you're
an employee of yours asks you
what should we do here
I don't know if it's this Cutthroat as
football but
I I think it's better to have an answer
than to say you don't know yeah yeah
right so even if you don't know because
it's giving them confidence even if you
don't know you say we're looking into
that we've worked on that you know
that's something that we you know just
make the moment you say you don't know I
think there's an element of um
yeah I think and I think it was
Guardiola who said it
um you know these wise words didn't come
from me personally they were they were
quite the owner's words and I think it
was something to do with
um if someone asked you a question you
have an answer for them
um even if you don't know it you'll
you'll go do your homework and come back
to to that question because you you need
to be seen as a level above
um The Players you need to have you know
more you need to be more clued up you
need to have more
um intricate details on the opposition
you need to know about football more
than the players do
um so they have that respect for you was
there other times you know you talked
about losing the dressing room now I
hear that on like from pundits I hear uh
maybe it's not a dressing room you
sometimes hear that from like other
commentators online but I I wondered if
that's an actual thing that happens that
you've observed where you go man I just
[ __ ] lost this now players start
questioning him you know behind his back
or yeah I think I think you can see it
um when did you see it uh I've seen it
at certain times I don't think it'd be
fair to me for me to say names
um but I have seen it in certain
dressing rooms where a manager has lost
lost it a little bit um we had
we had the situation at Stoke where we
had probably the best dresser room I've
ever been a part of
and then
we added sort of some more talented
players more than sort of hard-working
honest players if you like and we had a
for a spell we had a really good mix
of that real quality and that
kind of determination and spirit
um and then it went too far the other
way it was you know almost almost too
much quality and not enough effort
determination team spirit ethics
standards
they slipped you know and
asking things that I'd never seen before
um
I talked about the player walking off
the pitch that happened at in that in
that season and it culminated in in
relegation you know so when you talk
about lost the dress room rather than so
I classed myself in that in that
scenario because I was more of a I was
an older player then
and maybe I let things go
things go A bit as well you know like
this not my standards personally didn't
drop but I let people get away with
things when I was an older player like I
should have been the Stephen Gerard in
this situation you know I should really
reply that flagged it up maybe
um that wrangles with me like I I let
things go I know it wasn't my job to do
that but I was a an experienced player
um when you say you've not seen you saw
things you hadn't seen before it kind of
reminded me somewhat of what I remember
Rio saying about when he moved I think
it was QPR from Manchester United and he
saw just a completely different dressing
room culture
yeah exactly right well let's ask our
friends already I speak to him about
that time feels similar feels similar in
some ways like you you have almost too
many
um doing what they want
um you know just being late or little
little things like that like being like
being like on the training pitch being
like
um for games you know not wearing the
right
suit or not wearing the right track
suits again whatever they want you know
wearing caps when you're not supposed to
um just little things like that that
makes you become lacks like and we won't
go a goal down two goals down and you
can see players sort of you know waving
their arms around and not tracking back
and I remember asking a particular
player like
you stop trying you stopped working and
he said yeah I said
what and he said I did yeah I said why
he said we were three down
I couldn't believe it that's that you
know it's 30 000 people in a stadium
right that paid to watch us play and
you've given up
and I know it's hot it's horrible those
games they're horrible you just but at
least you got those run round
um and that's that's when I knew if we
were in big trouble
it's funny that it's the small the small
things like just yeah
they will light up
does that not start with a manager
though in those situations where the
manager is just not calling it out
enough he's not punishing you know he
lets one thing slide let's two things
slide before you know it you're at the
bottom of the [ __ ] slope yeah that
was exactly what happened
um there was certain things that were
let go and you're like well and then you
feel like you can get away with more
with more with more and there was a
certain thing you'd have to run after a
game if you didn't play so that time
like I was on I was 37 years old you
know I was sometimes I was on the bench
and I'd be out there running and you
know there was a younger player not not
out after the game doing this Fitness
work and I came in I'm like what's going
on you know
why why am I 37 I'm out here running
after a game and this 25 year old is
is not which I didn't want to he didn't
want to didn't want to right so these
are the standards I'm talking about so
you've got to that's that's you've been
asked to do it you don't pick and choose
whether you do it or not but that was
allowed to happen anyway it happened
again
anyways this particular player said
right because he hasn't run after
um the game we're all in on Sunday right
so the whole team come in on Sunday
um
we were coming this is supposed to be
our day off
so we're all in training and the
particular player didn't turn up for
training right so we're all in because
of because of him and uh and he doesn't
turn up so I mean you can imagine what
the what the lads are like but
just little I say little things I mean
that was a big thing but just standard
slipping and listen you know it all ends
everyone knows where it ends ends badly
when did you decide that your football
career was over tell me about that
decision and that that time in your life
uh yeah I was lucky I got the
opportunity to get out of that that
dresser room that I was in at slope
which was difficult
um and I got the opportunity to play for
the exact opposite at Burnley and I
finished in the Premier League and I
knew that I was done that season because
I was on the Venture lot and there was
players playing ahead of me that I knew
should have been ahead of me and my
thoughts myself
I am just a plan B now
um you know I'm coming at the end of
games and I still felt fit I still felt
I could have an impact but I knew inside
my own head so I told my family I told
um you know I told Abby and I told you
know the kids are still very young
and uh we all went to the game so they
you know they didn't all come out you
know a young baby you know they didn't
often come to the games now I didn't
play much
so they all came and it was nice because
I knew no one else knew but I knew that
it was my last game of football was
against Arsenal
um at at Burley and uh all the family
came on and you know when he walked
around the pitch at the end and I've got
a picture at home on the wall of me and
it was three kids we had at Target four
now I believe what not but the three of
us
um on the pitch and a lovely picture of
me walking out is my last game of
professional football I must have played
you know 600 700 games it was my last
game I knew it but no one else did
um but yeah lovely picture a lovely
moment and then it just sort of comes
flooding in that it's it's over 20 years
I played I left school at 16 I retired
at 38. 22 years every day of my life
doing something that you laughed I
looked back on it with such fond
memories I was so lucky to have played
um
in an era that was was full of great
players I managed to play for England
and you know I probably exceeded what I
thought I would could ever achieve so
always look back on it fondly when
people ask me
um no do you miss it no I don't miss it
I cherished the moments I had
I knew that was your dad there that day
I know you played a huge yeah that was
there that day yeah and uh you know he
was the one because he was there every
single I don't think he missed a game
and he was part of my Superstition uh
bizarrely he was part of
you know if I didn't see him before a
game I feel unnerved you know like I'd
feel like where is he and don't get me
wrong there were times where I was on
the bench towards the end and he got a
season ticket QPR
and deservedly so you know I didn't want
to put him through that
um but it was yeah I mean he was he was
with me or stepping away he came to
every game yeah yeah I really didn't I
don't think he missed many
handful you know of those 600 700 right
from when I was a kid
um so yeah it was like a comfort blanket
when I saw and he would he would watch
me
not even a kickoff he would watch me
he'd be the first in the stadium I would
walk out at
um
before the warm-up
and I'd see him and I'd always see him
you know six or five I'd always be able
to see him uh and he'd give me a little
wave and he'd watch how warmed up and
then after the game he'd even say like I
knew you'd have a good game in the
warm-up because he'd always watch even
the warm-up
so yeah when your career ended did you
ever ever have a conversation with him
about
um
about your journey in football I guess
was there ever like a any conclusive
conversations about how it all went and
yeah you know what like
uh we had sort of like a like a bit of a
retirement um video if you like and I've
got to cover a load of ex-players and
managers that I played with which was
nice and laid it put it on a big screen
um but I don't think I've ever sat down
and discussed at length
um
my career I mean life's too busy in it
you know like I look at I've got a you
know a wall like you have and a few sort
of accolades matchables ignorant caps on
the wall only in one particular room I
only allowed like a little dungeon room
um but I've got them on and I look back
and I look got some pictures on there
and I look at the moments and I think
like they were some great times
um but like I say life moves quick and I
love I love what I'm doing now and I've
gone straight into doing other things
and I was very conscious of that like I
planned I planned a little bit of that
you know I planned while I was still
playing I did the podcast and I did the
the first book that I did I like and I
did my coaching badges as well so my
coach I thought you know maybe I'll be a
manager I didn't know but I just
basically I was so scared of waking up
on that Monday because every player that
I've I've ever played with
says to me like when you're retired like
you've forgotten like that you it's
difficult it's hard to get your head
around it keep playing as long as you
can you always hear these horror stories
so I was so worried about it I just
thought right I need to do everything
now before I retire and I think it was
the best thing I ever did was to stay
was to do things while I was still
playing to to test things out and see
what I want to go into and start
building that bridge I guess a little
bit Yeah to the other side if you like
and um like I say the book and the
podcast just went bang and that I just
got propelled into a into a world in the
in the media really was there ever a
moment when you were after you'd retired
where you where you had a bit of a down
day and you thought you know because I
remember reading I think in your book
where you talk about how you spend those
20 years like everything sorted for you
your schedule sorted you know where
you're going to be you kind of know
there's so much structure in your life
and then suddenly the structure's gone
and a real clear sense of like
orientation and Collective purpose is
gone
was there ever a post-retirement moment
where you go ugh
I don't think I've had that really and I
feel really lucky like because I know so
many players that have really struggled
since they retired and I feel so lucky
in in what I'm doing now like I'd love
to sit here and I've got to be honest
with you no I can't I I have I haven't
had that and what I what I don't like is
not having that that structure like for
for instance I know exactly where I'm
going to be on September the 16th on you
know February the 12th I know where I'm
going to be I know where I'm going to be
training like now I couldn't tell you
what I'm doing next week like things
come up things change
um I don't like that I like I've been
institutionalized if you like I'm in a I
like getting told on a Monday we do this
and I don't wanna
it was I suppose for 20 years I didn't
have to grow up yeah you know now I do
um I came straight from school to people
no they should take our passports offers
you know we won't even allowed to they
didn't trust us enough to to get
ourselves to the airport you know it was
that's how football is everything's done
for you so you can purely concentrate on
football and I I quite like that in a
weird way because you you solely focus
on one thing whereas now
there's lots of different things that I
do
um and lots of choice choices yeah like
lots of decisions yeah it's like being
an adult it's not great
was the guy who was um imprisoned when
he was younger for a crime he didn't
commit sentence to life came out and he
was telling me it was like honestly when
I came out it's like I went to a
supermarket and there's like seven types
of beans yeah and he stood in the
supermarket and what the [ __ ] do I do
what do I do he hated it him and his
partner would Clash because he was never
used to making decisions in prison you
get one type of [ __ ] beans so true
love and I like that I honestly like
with with football like you are you that
you are told what had to be what to do
at all times until you're on a football
pitch or even something really that as
well you know your manager's telling you
what to do but I quite liked it in some
ways but obviously the freedom is great
in other ways you know like I have at
Christmas now I can spend time with the
kids if I choose to have a week off it
during the winter I can have that you
know there's there's pros and negatives
to both are you a workaholic
um I think I've got a good work ethic
definitely
um
without doubt I enjoy it I enjoy getting
up and having a purpose do you feel like
you're out of balance though yeah I'm
finding the balance really tough okay
yeah same really tough yeah
um obviously you know speak to other
about this as well because we I struggle
like I'll have one week where I'm
constantly on the go and
um and then we'll Wicked you know a
little bit quieter but yeah I sort of
soldered the dream of retirement as
being retirement and it hasn't quite
worked out that way because I love doing
what I'm doing where did you sell her
well I sold it like we'd be getting the
gym every day you know little juices
it would be on dog walks I said you know
they're just Rome yeah we'll go through
we'll go quality time
um and yeah it's not quite worked out
that way
but she knows I'm passionate about what
I do I'm very I love what I do now and
um I'm still involved in football which
I love you know like I like I say I do
the podcast that I absolutely love doing
and various other bits and pieces come
up and I'm in a fortunate position I
know I'm in a fortunate position to be
able to pick and choose
the stuff that I do and I do it purely
for enjoyment
um and of course you know I try and make
it as the best it can be and so I can
earn off it but the the main focus was
the same as my football career really
was to do something that you enjoy and
I'm lucky in the fact that I I can still
do that is your main
um
dispute in your relationship because
this is the answer for mine is is this
issue of quality time it's like that's
the thing I struggle with most is doing
all this stuff and constantly and then
being there to be to give this person
quality time that they want where you
just go for the [ __ ] walk and you
just do nothing it seems like nothing
but obviously there's something it's
something picnic but you must find that
hard like I I find that hard to but
she's the same you know
like um I think it'll be easy to say
that uh
I don't know like there's a
misconception of um maybe footballers
wives that you know they're just relax
all day and you know she's so driven and
she drives me to be honest and she's uh
I run all my decisions past her and I
don't think a lot of people know that
about her but she's like uh she's on it
and um you know so that's that's good in
the fact that if we go for a walk
together we'll have some quality time
together but we both won't switch off
together
you know like we're still bouncing ideas
off each other and um and I'm glad that
I can have someone like that so you know
yeah of course we switch off at times
but we we're still we're still very on
it both of us so your podcast absolute
smash here a lot of a lot of ex-players
ex-athletes have started podcasts
I can't think of any that have risen to
the heights that yours has risen to Mike
Tyson has a great podcast in the United
States
um
it's really been a bit of a cult
phenomenon the show and as you kind of
said you know I've heard you talk about
the drivers here a few times and it's
always you're always you know saying
very nice things and saying that you
know our production and stuff is is um
is great
but it is like a couple of lads in a pub
chatting yeah I suppose that is that is
our thing I I think it was it is a
reflection of me it's what I like to do
so and I think I suppose we could now
because things have gone well upgrade
our setup a little bit
um but it doesn't it feels like we need
to stay where we are we love being in
the pub we like
um you know having a bit of a drink
while we do it
um and it feels certainly during
lockdown
you know we have lots of comments from
listeners and people writing in and
they feel like they're in there with us
you know and it feels like obviously
this is a different kind of whole class
you know more serious more enlightening
maybe
um but I try and I try and take people
inside the world of what it's like being
a footballer and it's a mad funny world
it is and and of course it's
light-hearted but hopefully it's a
little bit informative as well and uh
when I say I love doing it it's
genuinely the most fun when I say to web
um I'm going to work
she's like are you joking
I've been there with the four children
and I'm going to uh to a pub in town
um to record with uh Lads that I get on
really really well with and um just
talking football I suppose that is
that is the you know for a lot of people
certainly in my world that's the ideal
job and I'm I feel very fortunate I've
got it
the podcast offers people that kind of
that sense of connection and Community
like they are in the pub with you
um which some people don't have
unfortunately these days and in a world
that's getting lonelier but at the same
time it's not just like it's not just
banter I remember seeing the episode
with Prince William and where you talked
about mental health and
um those kind of topics and I think one
of your your co-hosts I can't remember
which one shared um some of the feedback
that you guys get from the audience that
are listening that particular episode
with Prince William how the [ __ ] did you
get it from a fresh start
how did you how did you get Prince
William to come on I have a point with
you on the podcast there are points in
this podcast like obviously like where
it all started from I Didn't Have You
know I was just telling a story I don't
know what a podcast was you know
obviously now I know that you know
there's a huge industry of things but I
I was just talking literally as I was
talking to my how I talked to my mates
and uh obviously yeah we built up like a
like a big following and then people
started calling us about coming up about
coming on
um and that was a call we had from the
palace was was I promise you it was you
know we had we had there was one point
there was like we had Elton John I'd
called
and uh and Prince William had called not
not personally but you know their team
of people had called us about coming on
and
obviously uh without no that's a
different story it was funny but um with
Prince William you know we made it
happen and we ended up going to Kingston
Palace
um which was an amazing day out because
we we took it you know our our group of
lads and we had a we had a beer over the
road well we went in and then um you
know Prince William I talk about the
samrat you know the Indian restaurant um
that I used to go to with my mates as a
kid and when Prince William brought in
the delivery
um and put it down and I was thinking if
what you know my mates if you used to go
there as kids my family and you know
he's doing this and it was just so
surreal um but like you say we got to
talk about a range of topics and I
suppose you know certainly in football
there's a lot because there's a stigma
in football of um you know it's very
Macho and you have to you know you have
to be
um you have to man up you know like you
you have to there's this stigma and I
think that this is why sort of the
target audience for Prince William and
his heads I think his heads together or
heads up Charity
um for mental health is targeting the
right people if you like the people that
don't speak out
um so I think he wanted to tap into sort
of our audience that would be very much
uh don't show any weakness
um you know that football world if you
know what I mean so yeah I think that
was something that he wanted to to touch
touch base with I've done something with
him called a um uh a a team talk I think
it was a royal team talk I think it was
called on BBC and we talked about you
know mental health and stories and
football that's the first time I shared
my issues is um you know I'd never ever
talked about anything I was one of those
people that kept everything so yeah it
was a nice it was a it was great it was
a great experience for us as a podcast
and and I think hopefully it helped a
few people as well you talked about on
that podcast going into the changing
room and like opening up to your
teammates at one point
yeah I mean I I found it really
difficult to um I'm one of those people
that keeps everything inside right I
don't I wouldn't I wouldn't talk about I
see Abby every single night like
picking up the phone to my friends and
chatting about anything I mean I just
don't do that I don't I wouldn't dream
of picking up the phone and and ex you
know talk about a problem
um but since these kinds of things that
I've done since that podcast since uh
you know I've done a a various you know
the um November campaign I've worked
with them I've worked with uh various
kind of men's mental health Charities
and they it is it does make you think
and you know I have started doing more
stuff I have started you know reaching
out to my friends and you realize
actually that people aren't always
people say they're always all right but
they're not
there's something I've realized I think
the quote from that from that podcast
with um Prince William was you gone into
the dressing room you'd shared how you
were feeling with your teammates and
instantly you kind of felt lighter
because of it you felt better for
opening up yeah that's that's something
that I definitely found like I've
when was that
um
no that was the royal team talk we
opened up so it was me yeah Thierry
Henry
um Danny Rose who was quite open with
his mental health problems
um Gareth Southgate uh I think Dan
Walker that was the presenter and Prince
William
and like when when you actually get like
a
like a group of lads there talking like
Prince Prince William wasn't Prince
William you know Thierry Henry wasn't
Thierry Henry it was just a group of
blokes talking
and
you know Prince William's talking about
bereavement and you think you know oh my
God like you don't
I don't know it's like that's not real
it's like a not real life but you think
actually when he's sitting there he's
just a lad he's lost his mum
like yeah like
it was an amazing talk because you're
not seeing her as Princess Diana and
you're not seeing him as the Future King
of England you're seeing him as a man
who's struggling who's lost his mum
um and I think sometimes when you read
things and you you look at things
like I say it's that it's that thing of
playing football and not realizing that
they're actually it's on a human level
it's just he's just a fella that's
that's lost his that's lost his mum and
struggled with that over time and you
when you say you you opened up you're
referring to the stuff you've talked
about today with yeah me personally yeah
I opened up about uh yeah looking
different a bit you know like and
getting the heckled and
being sort of that impressionable
teenager and sort of dealing with that
with that kind of pressure of looking
different if you like
um bizarrely that's become sort of like
my superpower now uh it's become sort of
me it's like
unrecognizable I am um
I think people understand like all my
insecurities if you like
I've been what has probably made me
successful in in the stuff that I've
gone on to do
when you do look back at your success
and in hindsight and you go okay maybe
this was a big part of it this was part
of it what are the the key things that
in hindsight you go that's why I was
successful because earlier on you said
like most of the football players
especially the strikers didn't look like
you but you were still successful you
still played at the very top of the game
you still had the England caps you still
scored all those goals for England so
what was it about you
um I I listen I had I had ability
you know I did I did I felt like I was a
good player and I worked on that like
that was something that if I was going
to be tall I wasn't going to be this
what everyone thought I was going to be
you know
um which was that big Target you can
lump the ball up to you know I wanted to
have technical abilities I worked on
that I constantly worked on that
um so that was obviously something that
stood me out um and then I had to work
on my on my heading
um because I was incredibly tall but I
didn't have to jump as a young lad and
then when you get to play professional
football you then realized that you know
people are going to jump they're going
to beat you in the air and it looks
ridiculous if you're six foot seven and
you're losing headers so I had to work
on on my heading and obviously it's
determination it's the the world to
succeed
um it's the desire
um it's the ability to deal with
knockbacks
um that stand you out probably from from
the rest not backs ever did you ever
have a experience with especially
through the period with Liverpool where
you when it's 18 games without scoring
and the various twists and turns
throughout your career did you ever
experience anxiety
uh yeah I'd say so I mean listen I'm not
an expert on this field
um I I wouldn't say I'm an anxious
person
um like I say I'm a glass half full kind
of person but
um I would say of course like in
football in terms of course I was
anxious I was snatching at uh chances
um and was I anxious off the field yeah
couldn't switch off from it couldn't
stop thinking about it couldn't sleep
so couldn't sleep yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't have been able to sleep
um certainly after games but I found
that difficult anyway that the kind of
buzz that you get from playing a match
under lights especially is
so difficult to sleep after that I think
physically impossible at times where are
you now in terms of
your mental well-being and your mental
health yeah good good yeah like I would
never I would never um
I don't think I'd ask myself as ever as
having problems
um I've had issues that I've had to
manage personally like everyone has I
think but I'd say I'm in a good place I
just need to get the balance right
between
um you know this new field that I mean
if you like
and and family life you know I need to I
need to get the right the right balance
when I'm working enough to sort of
satisfy that
that hunger to keep going
um and not miss
what is important you know which is my
kids which are at the door and I want to
see
I want to see grow up um and I want to
be here at the Forefront of that I want
to be hands on you know so I've got to
try and work that balance out something
that's my biggest problem I always you
know I think I always hear this voice
which is like when is enough enough like
when is enough going to be enough like
podcast is going great business is going
great you've done achieve loads of
things like
um what else do you need when is enough
enough it's difficult one because I I
think it's that for me it's about it's
about like the work but I was about
enjoying it and um you know if it stops
being fun and I think that's the time to
to call it quits
crouchfest
19th of November yeah 19th of November
it's um I mean I've seen it because I
watched all the videos from like 2019.
yeah that's right [ __ ] life guys this
is so much fun yeah but the thing is
like people buy tickets and not have a
clue what they're letting themselves and
um it is one of the one of the best
things that we've ever done and we just
thought we'd scale it up this time last
time we had Liam Gallagher on I had
Catherine Jenkins singing the Champions
League Anthem or the fella that wrote
The Champions League Anthem spoke to us
uh Tom Grant and knew me at six we had
um you know people dressed as referees
fancy dress
um it was absolute Carnage and uh yeah
now we're at Wembley Arena we've scaled
it up Wembley around Wembley Arena yeah
so
I mean we've probably bitten off more
than we can shoot
but yeah great guests and and looking
forward to it so much what what what are
you promising for this Crouch first well
what that's the thing we don't promise
anything okay so you don't say anything
you really don't say a word to anyone
and we've got obviously I mean some of
the things that we've we've been getting
up to has been uh a lot of fun and some
of the knockbacks that we've had have
been been priceless because we're asking
things that Wembley Arena has never seen
before
um but yeah I'm honestly I can't tell
you how much fun the last one was and if
it was hot if it's half as good it will
be it'd be a great event well everyone
listening can there's a few tickets left
so you can go they're probably they
might not be by the time this comes out
but you can go buy tickets online for
Crouch first it looks like I mean I
watched the highlights from 2019 and it
looked like it looked like a huge group
of mates pissed having a laugh that's
exactly what it is yeah I can't dress it
up anymore but you're welcome to come if
I'm here I'll come for sure for sure
they look really really good what is is
what is your goal now what is next for
you you've all these things going on in
your life the media stuff you're
presenting on BT etc etc you've got the
podcast you've got this amazing book
you've just written well it's just come
out in October I believe how to be an
ex-footballer
um the reviews for this book are insane
much of the stories you've told
um told me today some of them are in
here some of them are in your previous
book but both books are Sunday Times top
bins bestseller
um what is next what is this yeah I like
I say like this
um I'm finding my feet I have no clue I
had no clue where I was gonna go I I
didn't know what angle to to go for
um I I'm doing things because I enjoy
them and like when you say what is your
goal
it it I don't want to come on here Diary
of a CEO right and everyone's got a goal
everyone's got a purpose everyone knows
what they're gonna do
I have to be honest with you I don't I
don't have a goal I I don't have I don't
want to be doing this in five years or
that in five years my goal was achieved
like all I wanted to be was a football
player all I wanted to do was be uh was
do it at any level
every single day and then I felt like I
did that I achieved it I achieved more
than I ever thought I would and now
everything is you know that that's
happening to me is is the things that
I'm enjoying and their roots and avenues
that I'm taking but there's no
particular goal
um I don't know that might be difficult
for you to not to to understand but I I
just can't I'm I haven't got a a motive
or a plan I'm just living each day and
enjoying each day
um that I'm given and I feel like I'm
blessed in the situation I'm in but this
is genuine that is the most genuine
thing I can tell you I don't have a an
end goal I think you'd be surprised how
um
common that is
I've you know I think people think that
I have everything figured out or so like
a North star a God but I've said on this
podcast a million times that I've never
written a business plan in my life it's
really about like doing my best today
and doing that every day and kind of
being open to the things that come along
because goals can also be really
unhelpful in the sense of like it might
make you miss an opportunity if you had
a goal when you left football to become
a coach you might miss the opportunity
to do the podcast
or all these other things well I feel
like it's also now reminded in some way
you go like you have the end goal but
like you say these missed opportunities
like every like I did the book I did the
podcast and things took off and then
opportunities come off the back of that
and as long as those things are going
well the opportunities will continue to
come and then you might find that you
enjoy something else or a different
Avenue and that is where I'm going I'm
on a journey that I have no clue where
it's going but I'm enjoying it and a
long way at last at the start you
mentioned that
the way you were treated when you're
younger looking a bit different meant
that you used kind of self-disparagement
criticizing yourself making a joke at
yourself first as a defense mechanism
much of the reason why people love your
books love your podcast is because
they're like really really funny and
they make people laugh
and even from like hanging out with you
today for a couple of hours whatever you
are one of those real funny people I
mean on the front of your book it says a
comedy genius I didn't like that by the
way yes you did it
no but I it's interesting I just find it
interesting as an observation that the
thing
that people criticized you for created
equality in you which is seems to be
from my very naive assumption like
critical now to your success and why
people are so fond of you is that an
accurate assessment oh there's a spot on
um you know I sort of I my kind of like
humor and being able to laugh at myself
was a was a self-defense mechanism where
people were trying to take the mick out
of me I would take the mick out myself
in a better way than they were about to
do so that makes me self
self-deprecating and I think that is
very uncommon for a footballer to be
self-deprecating it was groundbreaking
and I don't think it should be but let's
be honest I think it probably it was a
bit you know not many players that play
for England let their guard down at any
point or want to criticize themselves
um or have a laugh at themselves and
that and that that is something Navy
that has set me apart that I'm aware of
um from other players and that is not me
being contrived or you know trying to
force an agenda I think anyone who has
played with me over the course of 20
years will say to you this is the person
that they they knew in the dressing room
but I think I'm able to to Showcase that
a little bit more by being less guarded
because I haven't got a football club uh
telling me to not
talk too much or you know you're a
footballer shut up you're like now I can
do whatever I like and fortunately I've
been in a position where the hospital is
the general public or fans that are are
buying into what I'm doing are enjoying
it and um you know for as long as they
are enjoying it I'll continue to do it
and when they're not I'll [ __ ] off
it reminds me a lot of um Lewis Capaldi
who I sat with where he's just seems to
just be doing whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to do yeah
admire him so much you know like he's
the kind of thing that I you know I love
to see like and I watched it obviously
recently I think he was on Jonathan Ross
and uh I was brilliant like he's
hilarious and he looks like he wants
he's enjoying what he's doing and um you
know he's himself and I think that is
what I'm doing and I'm thankfully
um people are in hopefully enjoying it
100 they are enjoying it I think that's
a huge understatement and it seems to be
the case from the people I've sat here
with on this podcast
um seems to be the case that those that
are themselves that are able to build a
life based on being themselves
are living the most sustainable and
fulfilling lives it's [ __ ] difficult
not being yourself for a long period of
time and it's not fun right yeah well
you can't get tripped up if you're if
you're being yourself yeah you caught
the guard never slips does it but it
feels like a risk to some people well
let's see why yeah it's a risk if not
hey
you're right you're actually right it's
only a risk if you're a [ __ ] but
you're completely right
um be someone else if you're one of
those
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're gonna ask it for and the
question that's been left for you
is
what moment has caused you to be the
most afraid in your life
it's difficult I think I've been in
situations where um
none of this matters does it let's be
honest right I I'm thinking about
football terms I was thinking straight
away I went to like
what about when I didn't score when I
did this when I wasn't going to make it
as a footballer like or like none of
that matters does it
um
your family's the most important thing
and when you have a
a scare
personally
or you're one of your you know close
people your wife or your kids has an
issue
um
that is when you're the most scared that
you'll ever be and I think
you know I've had I've had those those
worries
um
and and that's when you you really
realize what's what's important
obviously when the
you know the the pandemic and you know
we were in lockdown and that kind of
thing and you realize actually
none of it matters you know like it was
just it was
I had my family and we were fortunate
obviously to be in a in a nice house and
I just thought
you know what we are incredibly lucky
even if we don't have
if we don't have anything we've got each
other you know and that I think that was
I think some most scared when someone
when when you have a scare with someone
close to you which we have had and um
you get through that that's that's the
Michigan that's exactly what came to
mind for me it was when I think it must
have been 10 and my mum
called me and told me I believe she
called me and told me she had cancer in
her breast because she had found a lump
and then it transpired it was assist it
was fine but that period of like
several days believing that my mum's
gonna die when I'm 10. yeah nothing I
mean everything else in comparison and
you realize that [ __ ] all matters as you
said yeah like that like it's so weird
like I went to like football then like
straight away then you actually think oh
wait a minute that doesn't matter does
it no it's really scared I've been is
when you have a scare in the family
without doubt Peter thank you thank you
for so many reasons thank you for
inspiring me in this podcast you've been
a big inspiration for us you know like
the production is one thing I know
you've commented on the production
before but what you have is something
that's so like authentic and Brilliant
and that's the impossible thing to
create to find like a authentic formula
that's resonant with with the audience
that you have and give so much to them
it's like it's it's a lot and it's not
[ __ ] easy and you know I I watched
your playing career I've watched you
know I've watched you play in all the
clothes you've played in the thing that
I'm like that is [ __ ] unbelievable is
actually what you've been able to do
since you know and that says a lot
because you've got to Champions League
finals and you paid for the best clubs
in the land but watching what you've
done since I think is even tougher
um that's just my perspective and I've
taken a huge amount of inspiration from
that your book is amazing Crouch first
is obviously going to be amazing because
you guys just have a magic that is like
um impossible to replicate and so
you got you know like it's fun to watch
you guys it's really really fun to watch
your journey and to not know where it's
going to go I mean like Prince William
walking in you're in this Pub toilet
like oh you know I just don't it's
[ __ ] brilliant and it's it's
perfectly authentically brilliant so
thank you for coming and doing this it's
a huge compliment to us that you come
and do it and it's been great to chant
you and meet you no my pleasure thanks
for having me I really appreciate it I'm
just laughing because I like smiling
I'm not a professional setup
so much
as you know Intel are now one of the
sponsors of this podcast and I'm here to
tell you about one of the latest Intel
Evo designs I've been recently using
this laptop and honestly I've been blown
away by how user-friendly it is to use
Intel has spent thousands of hours
studying the way people use their
laptops and then collaborating with
leading PC makers to co-engineer
optimize and test these laptops to
create the Intel Evo platform which
delivers the ultimate mobile experience
laptop designers only received the Intel
Evo badge after they've been rigorously
tested to pass Intel's own strict
requirements and deliver an ideal
combination of features such as long
lasting fast charging battery Wi-Fi
connectivity standards and a super slim
design the result is a premium laptop
that delivers an ideal combination of
features in the coming weeks I'm going
to break down exactly what features you
get when you buy an Intel Evo certified
laptop and how they've made my life on
the go 10 times easier to find out more
about the Intel Evo platform go to
intel.co.uk Evo and let me know how you
get on if you see me wearing jewelry
there's one thing thing you will know
for sure this has been the case since
before their sponsor of this podcast is
that I'm wearing crafter Jewelery their
pieces are my favorite they are my
favorite and as I said if you ever see
me wearing jewelry I guarantee you it's
crafted jewelry their new collection
here is my favorite ever it's the most
affordable brilliant versatile wonderful
high quality jewelry I've ever seen and
as I said the meaning of the pieces as
you can see if you look at some of these
pieces for me of course it's
interpretation but optimism
um Freedom those are the kind of hints I
get through my favorite piece of
Crafters of all time is actually a
similar piece to the one that Conor
McGregor has Conor McGregor has a
crafted piece
um and it's of the lion if you're
looking for male jewelry maybe for
Christmas or Black Friday or something
like that and you're looking for stuff
that is high quality that is high in
meaning and that is aesthetically
beautiful and on Trend look no further
than crafted
oh
my God